- [George] Tesla is going to win
Level 5, they really are.
- [Lex] So, let's talk about it.
So, you're focused on
Level 2, currently, currently.
- [George] We're going to be one to
two years behind Tesla,
getting to Level 5.
- Okay.
(laughs)
- [George] We're
Android, right, we're Android.
- You're Android.
- [George] I'm just
saying, once Tesla gets it,
we're one to two years behind.
I'm not making any timeline
on when Tesla's gonna get it.
- That's right, you did.
That was brilliant.
So, what do you think about
this. Most Level 4 companies
are kinda just doing their usual,
safety driver, doing
full autonomy kinda testing.
And then Tesla does, basically trying
to go from lane keeping to full autonomy.
What do you think about that approach?
How successful would it be?
- It's a ton better
approach, because Tesla
is gathering data on a
scale that none of them are.
They're putting real users
behind the wheel of the cars.
It's, I think, the only
strategy that works.
The incremental.
- Well, so there's a few
components to Tesla's approach,
that's more than just incremental.
You spoke with... One is software,
so, over the air software updates.
- [George] Necessity.
I mean Waymo and Cruise have those too.
Those aren't.
But those differentiate
them from the automakers.
- Right, no lane keeping systems have,
no cars with lane keeping
systems have that except Tesla.
- [George] Yep.
And the other one is the
data, the other direction,
which is the ability to query the data.
I don't think they're actually collecting
as much data as people think.
But the ability to turn on
collection, and turn it off.